نعم يعني فيما يتعلق باخر الاوضاع
الميدانيه خاصه في منطقه جنوبي قطع غزه
وبالتحديد في خانيونس حيث تستمر العمليه
العسكريه الاسرائيليه متزامنه او مصحوبه
بنيران كثيفه من الدبابات ومن الطائرات
المسيره والطائرات الحربيه المقاتله
والطائرات المروحيه التي تساند القوات
البريه التي تحاول وتواصل محاوله الدخول
الى عمق مخيم خان يونس على واقع هذه
النيران الكثيفه وارتفاع حصيله الشهداء
حتى هذه الساعه الى نحو اثنين و شهيدا
وعشرات من الجرحى وصلوا الى مجمع ناصر
الطبي في الساعات الاخيره جراء القصف
المتواصل على مراكز الاواء ومحيطها
ومواصله ايضا حصار المناطق الغربيه حي
الامل ومنطقه الحي الاماراتي والحي
الهولندي و
واحياء مخيم خان يونس ومحيط مجمع ناصر
الطبي والحي النمساوي ومستشفى الخير
وجامعه الاقصم علما ان هناك عدد من
الشهداء قد اضطر النازحون لدفنهم في مراكز
الاواء خاصه في مركز تدريب خان يونس
التابع لوكاله الغوث الدوليه الذي كان
ياوي نحو
66000 من النازحين الذين اتوا من مختلف
مناطق قطع غزه وقد نزحوا الى هذا المركز
منذ بدء الحرب على القطاع لكن بعدما هاجمت
القوات الاسرائيليه هذا المبنى بصوره
مفاجئه وقامت بحصار واطلقت النار صوبه ادى
ذلك الى استشهاد عشرات الفلسطينيين البعض
منهم جرى دفنه داخل هذا المركز والبعض
الاخر جرى نقله واجلاء الى مشافي مدينه
رفح جنوبي قطع غزه بعدما اعاقت القوات
الاسرائيليه وصول مركبات الاسعاف الى هذا
المكان ونقل الشهداء واجلاء المصابين الى
مشفى الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني القريب الذي
يشهد بالمناسبه حصارا اسرائيليا عبر
انتشار الدبابات محيطه كانت في ساعات
الليل وتراجعت قليلا وفي الساعات الماضيه
عادت للتمركز في احياء ا عده في منطقه حي
الامل خاصه الناحيه الشماليه من هذا الحي
الملاصق تماما لجمعيه الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطين التي تتعرض لنيران مباشره وتتعرض
ايضا لاطلاق قذائف من الدبابات وكذلك مجمع
عناصر الطب الذي يعمل بقدره 10% بحسب
وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه وقالت بان نيران
اسرائيليه طالت مبان عده في داخل هذا
المجمع الذي يشهد حصارا ايضا من الدبابات
خاصه من الناحيه الغربيه ومن الناحيه
الجنوبيه ايضا اوضاع النازحين تفاقمت في
ظل الحصار المتواصل من قبل القوات
الاسرائيليه التي تحاول التقدم نحو مراكز
ايواء خاصه مدرسه الامل التي اطلقت قذيفه
صوبها وهناك حديث عن عدد من الشهداء في
داخل هذه المدرسه فضلا عن محاصرين في
مناطق عده في حي الامل الواقع في المنطقه
الشماليه الغربيه لخان يونس ايضا عشرات
الاف الفلسطينيين تمكنوا من النزوح ظهر
هذا اليوم تحت النيران المتواصله ومن امام
الدبابات الاسرائيليه وسلوكا الى الطريق
الساحل ومن ثم التوجه الى دير البلح
والبعض منهم الى مدينه رفح في ظل اوضاع
قاسيه هم الان يبيتون في الطرقات وفي
الشوارع لان رفح قد امتلات بالنازحين
وتجاوز تعداد من وصلوا اليها المليون و2
الف حتى هذه اللحظه وفق احصائيات رسميه في
رفح ايضا كان هناك عدد من الشهداء بفعل
عدد من الغارات الجويه خاصه في المناطق
الشرقيه في المنطقه الوسطى من قطاع غزه في
الساعات الاخيره كان هناك 11 شهيدا جرى
قصف عده منازل سكنيه في النصيرات ومنطقه
الزوايده بينهم الصحفي اياد الرواغ الذي
يعمل في اذاعه ال شكرا لك هاني الشاعر كنت
معنا من رفح